انا جاي ادور على ابني مصاب ومش ملاقيه
واليهود هدين المستشفى على الجرحه وع
المرضى حتى الدكاتره ما سالمين منهم ولا
دكتور ولا حدا شوهدا كل
التراب اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قوات الاحتلال تدفن
عشرات المرضى والنازحين احياء بعد دهس
خيامهم بالجرافات بساحه مستشفى كمال عدوان
في شمال قطاع خس المرصد الاور متوسطي
لحقوق الانسان يطالب بتحقيق دولي في
معلومات عن دفن جيش الاحتلال مصابين احياء
بساحه مستشفى كمال عدوان وبعد استشهاد
الزميل المصور سامر ابو دقه شبكه الجزيره
تدين وتحمل اسرائيل مسؤوليه استهداف
العاملين مع الجزيره وعائلاتهم بشكل ممنهج
سي انان تنقل عن الجيش الاسرائيلي قوله
انه لم يتعمد استهداف الصحفيين لكن اطلاق
النار بمنطقه نشطه ينطوي على مخاطره بحسب
زعمه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط بالتعليق الاول الديوان الاميري
الكويتي يعلن وفاه امير الدوله الشيخ نواف
الاحمد الجابر الصباح عن عمر 86 عاما في
حين نادى مجلس الوزراء الكويتي بالشيخ
مشعل الاحمد الجابر الصباح اميرا للكويت
وكان الامير الشيخ نواف الاحمد الصباح قد
دخل المستشفى في نهايه شهر نوفمبر الماضي
اثر وعكه صحيه
طارئه موجه حر شديده تجتاح اجزاء واسعه من
استراليا ما دفع هيئه الارصاد الجويه في
البلاد الى اصدار تحذيرات من اندلاع حرائق
الغابات في ولايات عده وولايه نيو ساوث
ويلز الاستراليه تشهد اشتعال 50 حريقا كما
تم فرض حظر كامل على اشعال النيران في
العديد من المناطق بما في ذلك مدينه سيدني
البنك المركزي الالماني يقول ان توقعاته
تشير الى انكماش طفيف لاقتصاد البلاد هذا
العام ياتي هذا في ظل ضعف الطلب من الخارج
والحد من الدعم الحكومي للتحول الاخضر
وتضرر النشاط الاقتصادي من ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده الى
اللقاء